over the last 10 20 years we've seen a
change in the way stadiums are designed
it's sort of an arms race and that NFL
stadiums have been getting bigger and
more elaborate each stadium has to have
something more or better than the
previous lid and then FL stadium
nowadays you're not going to build for
under a billion dollars I think the
thing that will shift the mentality away
from the we have to spend a billion
dollars will be there won't be a billion
dollars hosta taxpayers was thirty four
point six million dollars is one year
eighteen million dollars in taxpayer
money on a new arena just six days after
the city filed for bankruptcy there'll
be places that it's it's it's really
hard to just say okay if you don't build
me a billion-dollar Stadium I'll have to
move but over the next 10 20 50 years
we're gonna see a shift in the way that
we think about stadiums in the new
stadium the stadium of the future it's a
neighborhood that's a completely
walkable completely connected
restaurants bars meeting areas Suites of
all different kinds the stadium itself
will become part of the downtown if you
are making this big investment in this
infrastructure there must be a way to
make it more useful to the city and more
integrated with the city so that if
you're building bars and clubs and
things like that into the building
that's supposed to support the game day
what if those bars are open restaurants
are open all week
it's kind of the current state of the
digital model I talked to Danny's who's
a stadium architect he's probably best
known for designing the Staples Center
in Los Angeles if you can find a
location in the city and design the
buildings so that they've been spills
out it becomes a big entertainment
destination that happens to have an
arena Dan loves this idea of a public
square a public space take it to an
extreme if he had his way the best
stadium would be no stadium at all it
would be something that is put up just
for a particular event and taken down
after and the public space returns to
where it was before
take the event off the pitch pull it
outside of the building and create other
reasons for people to be there then it
becomes lasting beyond you know through
the game itself the jockeys ride a
difficult course without saddle so the
Palio called the Palio D Siena is a
horse race that takes place twice a year
in a Town Square Museum it's featured at
the beginning of the James Bond movie
Quantum of Solace
for the entire year it's the regular
town square in Siena
but two days out of the year they turn
this town square into a horse racing
track so I think that there'll be a
forced shift to buildings that are
transforming so maybe they grow to
70,000 that day just like Siena and the
Palio and then they go back to a much
smaller manageable day I think today's
stadiums are by design going to be
required to participate more in the
communities that they're being designed
and constructed in populous is a Kansas
City based architecture firm and work on
every Super Bowl getting the venue set
up for the entertainment aspects a
project that I've been associated with
Sporting Park here in Kansas City for
Sporting KC we really tried to integrate
it into the surrounding and make it part
of much bigger hole so it wasn't just an
isolated Stadium sort of in a field
ellaby's a football team love to see the
Raiders stay but I don't think there's a
stadium ant all the proposals in LA or
well over a billion dollars and I think
that when there's public financing
involved I think that it is incumbent
upon us as designers to try and find
ways to program and integrate the
stadium into the community that we're
designing it for populous took their
team of stadium designers and looked at
how are we going to design stadiums
what's going to be different what's
going to change
so imagine walking down whatever
downtown street it is and you have a law
office and you have an office tower and
from the street it looks like a typical
office tower but then on the backside
you're overlooking a sunken football
field with a lower bowl that still has
twenty thirty forty thousand seats in it
but now that upper bowl is a ring a ring
of shops restaurants maybe even a
Transit Center part of your fields
actually accessible during the week
it's a gathering place it's a central
social area for people to get together I
think that our buildings have to become
more adaptable than they have been in
the past in order to be able to be
whatever it needs to be for what
Rabanne happens to be going on in that
stadium at the time
I've done a building in Japan that is a
twenty thousand seat arena that can
expand to a thirty thousand seat soccer
stadium if that became the norm and
people realized that what we're not
going to get a million dollars just
until the football stadium and eight
hundred million dollars to build a
baseball stadium and five hundred
million dollars of the marina
they'll think different will have to
you